is your code a big old ball of mud or
maybe you work on one at your
engineering place of work where you work
what is a big old ball of mud code base
i'm about to get into that because i got
a little website article review to do
let's check it out and talk about it
this is a computer science thing it's
pretty old from saturday june 26
1999 to be exactly by brian foute and
joseph yoder from the department of
computer science in illinois ravana
campaign i don't know
so
i came across this from some subreddit
and thought it was really interesting
and oh boy
my first code bases that i wrote am i
guilty or am i guilty of the big old
fall of mud yes very so this is a very
very long article about patterns and
design of code and i just want to kind
of do a quick video review of it because
it is pretty darn long but oh boy did it
hit home for me and some of the stuff
i've worked on in the past
would highly recommend slapping this bad
boy right into your reading list and uh
yeah have at it because it's it's a good
read it really is
all right so what is the big ball mud
big ball mud is a casually even
haphazardly structured system in
organizations if one can call it that is
dictated more by expediency than design
yet its enduring popularity cannot
merely be
indicative of a general disregard for
architecture but
you're basically your code base
is all over the place you just slap
everything together you're just like i
got this work and throw it in there got
this working slap that in there too and
you end up with code that's tied
together in all sorts of weird ways and
trying to modify it once it grows it's
like trying to figure out a ball of mud
basically it's it's nuts all right so a
number of additional patterns emerge out
of big ball of mud we're going to
discuss them and two principle questions
underlie these patterns why so many
existing systems architecturally and
just with the what can we do to improve
them what can we do to improve them
that's that's also the important
all right so as you might expect it's
all about
spaghetti code haphazardly structured
sprawling sloppy duct tape bailing wire
spaghetti go jungle i love that term
spaghetti code jungle look at this guy
over here just messing with all right
so how do these come apart or come come
to fruition to begin with usually
there's there's two different ways and
oh boy am i guilty i wrote this program
called dm power for dungeons and dragons
dungeon masters and it was one of the
first big pieces of software i wrote and
i basically just threw it together and
got it working however i could and it
became a big bold mud and it still is to
this day but it works fine uh i don't
know maybe other people would call it a
big ball mud but i definitely would
because i wouldn't do it the same if i
went back and did it again so it's
basically another term for spaghetti
code so you want to wonder
how does this
come to fruition well one of the big
things they talk about
is throwaway code so sometimes you just
need something to work you're looking
for examples you find a good example
maybe online maybe on stack overflow
maybe from a tutorial and you take that
working example
and you just put it in your code base
you just slap it in there it was
supposed to be a one-time example
throwaway code just to teach but then it
ended up in a code base and that's not
how it's generally supposed to work
usually you want to carefully architect
it in there so that is maintainable
rather than just throwing in chunks and
hoping for the best
so usually that happens when people are
in a hurry and you want to kind of get
it out there as soon as possible
all right so
there is a lot of little terminologies
in here like keeping it working piece
metal growth shearing layers sweeping it
under the rug we're not going to go all
of them over all of them but i just want
to give you the general point
so
the peace metal growth thing
is basically where you're just attaching
little random pieces here and there and
it's just growing but at kind of a
random rate or random random systems are
just kind of popping up and you're just
sticking them to some part of the code
somewhere and it's just kind of randomly
growing and no real rhyme or reason well
maybe there's a reason but definitely no
rhyme
[Music]
and generally what you want to do is
refactor a sustained commitment to
refactor can keep system from subsiding
into a big ball of mud
but when new things
come
out or you come across new systems
rather than just kind of slapping it on
the side somewhere what you actually
probably want to do is refactor and
implement it in there in a way that
really makes sense
did i mention this article is really
long
we're gonna we're gonna blast through it
you can imagine what sweeping it under
the rug is it's basically when you have
an area and you just
kind of prettify it a little bit maybe
put a little tiny front end and ignore
everything else there
totally guilty don't feel bad
now one of the big forces that seems to
cause this is being in a hurry time
because sometimes you gotta meet
deadlines and you don't have time to
refactor and design and architect
everything perfect you gotta have it
done and get it out there as soon as
possible this is not necessarily a bad
thing
however someone else should probably be
looking at your code this is also
something
that inexperienced coders might do or
someone that's not so committed to
architecture might do when they're
working on a code base
so let's talk a little about cost
because architecture is expensive it is
pretty expensive
to put everything together perfectly
as it says here programmers with the
ability to discern and design quality
architectures are reputed to command a
premium
yes you might already know this but good
programmers tend to be pretty expensive
to hire they're not just going to
make it your great code base for super
cheap
if you hire a
inexperienced programmer they're going
to have to learn a lot of things on the
job this isn't also isn't necessarily a
bad thing what that means is you're
gonna get a lot more mud and a lot more
spaghetti but if they're smart they're
still gonna be able to get it to work
and maybe they'll be able to fix it up
later so this is one of those things
that just comes with experience
often initial versions of a system are
vehicles whereby programmers learn
what pieces must be brought into play to
solve a particular problem
i definitely ran into this a lot while
designing my game engine ancient archer
and i still do to this day i just did a
big refactor
and it was a good time i streamed some
of it
yeah that's basically an advertisement
because this video is sponsored by me in
my decision to make videos so consider
slapping buttons and supporting me skill
programmers different level of skill has
expertise
predisposition and temperament that's
kind of a no-brainer we already know
that don't we let's move on
uh
the old shanty town spaghetti code big
ball of mud those are the different
things you might hear it called
typically it's spaghetti code i really
like the uh big ball of mud analogy i
think that's a fun one
shanty towns are usually built from
common inexpensive materials and simple
tools
using relatively unskilled labor wait a
second unskilled that's no way to talk
about your fellow coder there is little
overall planning and regulation of
growth oh boy
there are a lot of quotes in here like
there's one about skill from ralph
johnson on average average organizations
will have average people
you need to deliver quality software on
time and under a budget
often the people who control and manage
the development process simply do not
regard architecture as a pressing
concern they just want to see
it pushed out
and finished
but what happens here is the people
planning it who want the thing done they
don't know about the workmanship they
don't want to pay for it
because it's not a thing if it works
then it's fine ship it
that's how this vicious cycle is often
bored
now this is tricky to talk about in a
way that is productive because it's easy
to get in your headspace that the big
ball of mud or spaghetti is just totally
bad and now you should never do it but
the thing is you have to do it sometimes
it happens there's not a perfect
solution other than to take time
properly architecting it because
sometimes
it's raining and you just need to get a
roof up or you need to get that umbrella
up so you don't get soaked theoretically
but one of the things that is the cause
of that is you focus on features and
functionality then focus on architecture
and performance
while this is too long to all put in a
video essay i'm gonna just highlight a
few more important pieces of this and
kind of fly through the rest
we'll see here
that there are some general statements
and rules
such as well architecture has been
undervalued for so long that many
engineers regard life
with a big ball of mud as normal and in
fact some engineers even get quite
skilled at navigating these quagmires
been there how many times do you follow
your functions only to not understand
why we would be going here or there
apparently this term originated from a
guy named brian merrick the term appears
to have arisen in the 70s as a
characterization of lisp
oh boy
this does kind of get really messy and
hard to maintain if you ask me
all right looks like we're gonna finally
get into ways to combat the big ball of
mud although some of them might be
somewhat obvious already just the act of
scrutinizing
your code
and just refactoring repair
repairing it rehabilitating it that's
one of the ways you can combat it and
they're calling that here exposing it to
daylight
and
wait for it
the term everyone hates the hair here
pair programming yeah
you can't code alone all the time or can
you
a lot of people think pair programming
is just a total waste of time
but with two heads rather than one
sometimes one of the one of the people
can take a more
directorial approach while the other one
does the actual coding so in this
respect one
drives while the other rides shotgun
and in this way
[Music]
the code is often more heavily
scrutinized and talked about rather than
just thrown together there are three
ways to deal with big balls of mud it
says the first is to keep the system
healthy conscientiously alternating
periods of expansion and consolidation
refactoring and repair enhance a
system's architecture and structure as
it evolves
and now we've talked about this next one
before throw away the code and start
over the jim keller method i made a
video on that before it is a real thing
and sometimes it needs to be done but
don't do it too quickly
as i learned very recently actually just
this weekend as i was figuring out
skeletal animations and hammering away
at it putting time in reading i finally
solved the problem i was having for the
last couple weeks and it turned out to
be a lot smaller than i thought it would
be turns out i was looking in the wrong
place but i was literally about to throw
away everything and start over when all
i really had to do was change the right
lines of code so be careful thrown away
too soon to try to fix an unknown
problem try to understand the problem
you're fixing
before you rewrite it that would be my
personal recommendation there
the reconstruction pattern explores this
drastic but frequently
necessary alternative the third is to
simply surrender to entropy and wallow
in the mire
oh my
throwaway code the quick hack kleenex
code disposable code scripting killer
demo permanent prototype boom town i
love the pictures they throw in here
they're just spot on aren't they
we talked about this briefly but this is
just about getting things done quickly
and just sometimes you want a demo you
want to show something and you end up
with
just hacked together code that's very
quick but it looks looks nice i mean the
the results look nice it does the job
does what's supposed to and so you end
up saying all right just put it in there
let's move on
and that's where this problem arises
because you keep doing that and it just
becomes a giant
unorganized mess basically
so as you're adding in this new
throwaway code usually what you're
considering is well you want to keep it
working and you got to make some premier
considerations they say deciding whether
to extend or enhance the system and
sometimes you got to do a little
reconstruction there to get it to work
right
and look nice but you don't want to be
doing the old piece metal thing where
you just kind of adding adding a plate
to the side
all right now we get to piece metal
growth we've already talked about this a
little bit urban sprawl iterative
incremental development as you might
expect this is literally just adding in
little pieces here and there extending
and extending the the shanty town adding
a couple more houses and just kind of
hacking together a new road no
particular rhyme and reason we just need
another one so put it in there kind of
thing the biggest example of this seems
to be about urban planning
and how sometimes towns and developments
grow in ways that aren't exactly planned
just because they need to account for
more space
more people coming in more land
ownership
i think you probably get the point of
this one so we're not going to spend a
whole lot of time on it and basically
the way to combat this is to
plan it out take some time
to structure it in there properly all
right let's talk about the keep it
working
vitality baby steps daily build first do
no harm now i think this one has really
taken a
something of its own because we see it
often with things like continuous
integration
where every build needs to succeed
whenever we push new code otherwise we
don't throw it out
so if the build succeeds and passes all
the tests then you are keeping it
working and that's a fine thing
but also you gotta make sure you're not
falling victim to any of these other
anti-patterns where it's growing in
unsustainable ways
maintenance needs have accumulated
but an overall
but an overhaul is unwise since you
might break the system
i have definitely experienced this you
probably have to my the example my
personal example that comes to mind is
from
definitely from this piece of software i
mentioned earlier dm power
it was not built with any particular
architecture in mind i was very new at
the time i started writing this and when
i added new classes new systems new
feats
new skills
and just new features in general i
basically just hacked them in there and
oh boy
did it get messy and messy er
but you know what
i never really refactored it not not
once it was working
i basically just kept it working that
that was my only goal when adding stuff
was to keep it working now i was unaware
of a lot of the patterns or even nightly
builds or anything like that when
i was building this and i never really
did i never really spent the proper time
to do that this actually works fine it
works it works great it does what it's
supposed to do and i'm not particularly
uh encouraged to refactor because this
is totally unfunded
free piece of software and i don't even
think i'm allowed to get it funded
because if i ever get paid for this
piece of software i could probably get
sued by wizards of the coast because i'm
using so much of their stuff that i have
no idea if it's legal or not i was
basically building it for me and for me
i just wanted it to work all right i'm
getting a little sidetracked now
but i think you get the point of keeping
it working sometimes
you might be adding cool stuff and it's
all going great but it ends up just
getting uglier and uglier and you really
actually need to think about it and
refactor some of this growth
so let's talk about shearing layers
this is a pretty interesting one because
it's sort of like
you know when they put together a new
building you often have all this
temporary scaffolding up around it so
that the workers can get up there and do
what they need to do and place the
initial structure and that way they can
build around that
this is something like that so your code
is going to grow you're going to have
temporary pieces in there and sometimes
what you got to do is take off those old
layers that you no longer need that once
served a purpose but no longer do the
layers change at different rates
but the site
is eternal your piece of software
and what it does is there but some of
the
scaffolding no longer belongs once
you've gotten to a point where you need
to build better more permanent pieces
and this is somewhat about taking out
obsolete code
there are some tips about how to handle
this and it's really all about
adaptability and stability and
sustainability
and factoring your system so that the
artifacts change at similar rates
together
sweeping it under the rug
house cleaning pretty face quarantine
hiding it under the bed rehabilitation
potemkin village
i don't know what that means
there are so many analogies for this but
i think this says it
in the most plain way if you can't make
a mess go away at least you can hide it
one of the most spectacular examples of
sweeping a problem under the rug is the
concrete sarcophagus that the soviet
engineers construction constructed to
put a 10 000 year lid on the infamous
reactor number four at chernobyl
how exactly do you fix that problem you
kind of gotta just cap that one but it
is definitely swept under the rug the
problem's still there there is no easy
fix for that one
but when you're coding
and you have some really messy code
do you hide it behind an interface or do
you fix it up now we've probably all
been guilty of hiding the ugliest
private code behind
some sort of proper interface but this
tends to grow in ways that is somewhat
unmaintainable because when you come
back to that code under the rug it's
often just
all over the place particles and when
you get in there you get all dirty and
you're like what am i doing
overgrown tangled haphazard spaghetti
code is hard to comprehend repair extend
and tends to grow even worse
if it is not somehow brought under
control well-engineered code
should be
comprehensible
and they say attractive
what is its attractive code exactly i
guess just well put together code
nice variable names that sort of thing i
like to think of this as about
about headspace when you go to work on
something you have to put all that
temporary knowledge in your headspace
about what you're working on like how
some of these systems that aren't
frequently used work what variables it's
editing
and what it does and all of that however
when you have
this really messy code and you try to do
that it ends up also spaghettifying your
brain or at least that's what happens to
me and it takes a lot longer to make the
changes you want to change because you
gotta wrap your head around these
oddities that shouldn't
be like this
basically so the best way to make it go
away
is to
make it super nice
rather than restricting the border
restricting the area
reconstruction the total rewrite
demolition throw away the first one
start over i love doing this this is one
of my favorite things and for me
personally one of the reasons i love
doing this is because i just love typing
out code and thinking about it
that is just something that i inherently
find fun and that's probably one of the
reasons i'm a programmer is i just like
doing it i don't even care what i'm
working on sometimes i just want
something to work on so that i can have
it
in my head i don't want to be vegging
out on media and stuff all day i want to
be cranking my my brain whistle
that's something i just made up don't
quote me on that also one of the reasons
coders tend to like gaming is because it
has us critically thinking all the time
so when do you do this
well basically when your code has
declined to the point where it's beyond
repair or comprehension this can happen
quite suddenly and rapidly when you're
adding in new parts
and you're putting new pieces in
sometimes you just you know you're kind
of attaching things getting it working
for the moment and after a while
it becomes somewhat of a mess
and sometimes what you need to do is you
need to refactor it with these new
systems in mind
and take out all the obsolete code
this can be one of the most expensive
things time wise however
it can also be one of the most
beneficial in the long run now some
people won't do this because they see it
as admitting defeat
sometimes
it's easier to throw a system away and
start over
starting over can be seen as a defeat at
the hands of the old code or a victory
over it one reason to start over might
be that the previous system was written
by people who are long gone doing a
rewrite provides a new personal new
personnel with a way to re-establish
contact between the architecture and the
implementation i like this and i think
this is pretty valid often if
programmers are handing off old software
just trying to figure out what and why
can take a lot of time
and just refactoring the whole thing
rewriting the entire thing can be better
it might take a little bit more time but
you'll have a better understanding of it
and i think that's actually quite
important and i've done that myself
quite a bit i've often just tossed out
old code and started an entirely new
version
basically because i was having a hard
time wrapping my head around how the
systems were working
and it seemed like it would be a good
exercise to basically rewrite the whole
thing
another motivation for building a new
system might be that you feel you've got
the experience you need to do the job
properly this is a good one especially
for new coders it is true
so one of the ways to get experience is
you just need to get in and do it and
you might be inexperienced when you're
putting things together i have
definitely been there all pretty much
all my first software that i wrote i was
very inexperienced when i was doing it
and i knew that it wasn't going to be
revolutionary and it wasn't going to be
something that the world used and looked
up to was the next big thing but
i really wanted the experience and
the assignments i was getting at
university didn't feel like they were
giving me proper experience so i came up
with my own ideas and implemented my own
things
and once i was halfway through or
through with a big section of it i often
came across
new patterns or new ideas or learn
things that i didn't know before and i
just thought
ah man if i only knew this sooner i
would have wrote this differently
perfect time to rewrite because now you
can rewrite it with your new experience
in mind and it's it feels so good i've
been there i can still reference back to
this dm power because this is exactly
how this came up
about i had no idea really what i was
supposed to be doing or how i was
supposed to be arranging things or how i
should be doing my classes when i should
be using inheritance and stuff like that
but as i basically finished or started
doing the initial versions of this there
were times when i was like oh the way
i'm doing it's not going to work and i
would just completely scrap everything
and start over with my new knowledge in
mind and this helped me immensely i can
probably even accredit this
piece of software to getting me one of
my pretty big
first jobs in coding because at one
point
this little piece of software had like
50 stars and i made it private for a
while so it lost all its stars now it's
only got like five but when i was a new
at university and i i was the only
student that had a public repo with a
whole bunch of stars from their custom
thing it looked really good and it
looked really good on my resume but
really i had no idea what i was doing
and i was scared i was going to get sued
if it got too popular since uh i was
basically just using a bunch of stuff
from the uh dungeons and dragons books
and slapping it all in there with my own
systems around them
but i've since learned that i should
probably not care about that too much
unless i'm actually making money from it
and i'm not it's only a personal project
but i got yelled at for it i would just
make it private again and it's not going
anywhere or i would probably try to work
with a person being like look uh
buy it we buy it yeah yeah all right
let's uh move on
architect's most useful tools are an
eraser at the drafting board in the
wrecking bar at the site
so basically yeah just do it
just if you feel like it needs rewritten
go for it now in this day and age the
great thing about this
is we have version control so you can
just set your old version aside and
start a whole new one without deleting
and wrecking everything
i hope you have enjoyed this video ssa
about the big ball of mud the spaghetti
code and maybe have some ideas
going forward
highly recommend visiting the site and
all the acknowledgements and everything
are here it's a lot it's a lot of
information i tried to cover the basics
so that you can kind of get a
general understanding of these concepts
and these ideas and how to handle things
just even if just a little bit
so thank you for watching my video here
on code tech tutorials my name is matt i
make videos about
all things code and uh generally
whatever i feel like i try to put them
out as often as possible
and i could use your support and keeping
these going just a like or a sub
means a lot if you want to go the extra
mile and get some bonus stuff bonus
content because i do post member only
videos hit the join button down below
and join the channel it's super cheap is
the is the price of an overpriced
starbucks coffee actually less than that
per month and it would mean the world to
me
we also have a growing discord that is
full of other coders that love to talk
about anything code related so if you
need some more code related stuff in
your life consider joining the code tech
tutorials discord and chatting us up we
got some new features such as an auto
leveling system
all the old school members are kind of
out of that because they've been around
forever but uh yeah if you get in there
you can get levels don't worry the
levels don't actually mean anything
other than you've probably been there
and chatted for a while but uh yeah we'd
love to hear your ideas hear your
insights and talk about programming and
stuff and learn from each other and we
also have an area to share projects well
you get the point just just join it all
right we'll see you there and i'm going
to drop a few other links that are free
for
for you to help support me like well
this channel doesn't quite
make ends meet yet i would love for it
to so helping me grow means a lot but
i'm going to leave a few links to some
other things i do to keep my finances in
check and some of those are just
investing so i'm going to leave a link
to coinbase where you can get into
crypto and stuff and maybe i'll make a
little video about that but i don't want
to be an advisor because i ain't
responsible for all your decisions
however just joining via my link gets
you a little bit of free bitcoin and me
a little bit of free bitcoin for
referring to you
it's a non-sponsored link but it would
help me and also i'm going to do the
same for a trading website called weeble
and if you join via my link you get some
free stocks and i get a little bit of
free stock so it just helps me out and
since this is an unsponsored video i
feel okay dropping those in there i
appreciate you guys and i'll see you in
the next episode peace out guys
you